could be a solid offensive compliment of Play
here's tamarus a backand weakly across the
goal Mo timens back it goes Simmons gets it
back steps up in front scores John savaris 9
99 well that gives your offense a real
spark doesn't it it's not just the goal
but who gets it and it's the end of a good
long hard shift of keeping this Play Alive
a couple of chances where on the point being
pressured this is a d Tod pass that ends up
getting around and Timmons with his head up
able to make the play bzo is a big physical
guy watching him leaning on but as he turned
air you see that quick little spin bzo lost
his balance 16.3 on the clock tarus against
pasio a clean win for the Leafs KN Lander in
front a tip by Matthews y back to nander another
shot incoming BL pun for Morgan Riley has tied
it jaar's tipped that one in front I
think there's the reaction it's not
just about the goal to tie the game bench
finally realizes that tar has got a little
piece of it and the Leafs have been given
permission to empty the pitch that picture
worth 1,000 points as it's a milestone
night for the leaf Captain here tonight
well we just watched replay after replay
of close calls in front of soken and this
time it gets through and it's Morgan Riley
who's going to get the goal but it's tarus
who starts it wins the draw and then gets to
the front of the net where all the traffic's
going to happen one chance what a play
by Marner to keep it alive there there's
off of tarus chips over to Morgan R look at
the pointing right away they're celebrating
Morgan Riley's goal but more importantly they
right go after number 91 and the captain's got
[Music] 1,000 and extra Bounce from
dad there as the tar family and look
at that reaction storybook for him to
do it in this building in this way wow